this talk is about turning notebook into
a web app with Mercury and there's no
par knowledge expected and the two
present is Alexandra and Peter oh
Alexandra and Peter alexand Peter
background on them is Alexander is a
lawyer graphic designer with a passion
for promoting data science tools and
Peter has a PHD in compter computer
science and is an author
hello
Myra is there uh I I will show you the
easy way uh to turn your notebook into
the web app uh do you like to create
user
interfaces
no me me too so you know
uh my my my favorite
uh my favorite uh task when I working on
uh some data science project is waiting
till till till my model converge so
during this time I can watch YouTube
movies so uh with Alexandra we are
running company called ml jar and we are
working on data science tools and our
tools are open source
and we have two main tools the first one
is alml the second is Mercury and our a
ml is open source it is on MIT license
and it it has around 1 million of
downloads and people are using it uh in
some research papers so I'm very
surprised with this but it's okay and
and this Al ml is a it integrat creates
a bunch of uh packages from python
ecosystem it it works with tabular data
and it automates the full uh Bine of
creating machine learning model and I I
think that the Healer feature of of this
package is automatic documentation so so
at the end of the of the training you
have model of course but you also have
full documentation for this model and so
here you have some
visualization of of of uh of
documentation for the model so the
automl has very simple API we have only
two methods fit and predict and in in
the input you have tabular data and in
the output you have leaderboard and a
lot of different files and uh
documentation in markdown and each and
HTML
and what do you do after creating the
machine learning pipeline you need to
explain your results to your boss and
have you ever feel like
that yeah so so uh I I was very
surprised when I realized that not
everyone can code in
Python yeah and and I think m m mainly
because of this you can not just share
your uh code share your
notebook
and non technical users don't know
python they don't know how to set up the
environment they they they don't have
access to the hardware to the data set
so you cannot share your notebook
directly with them it's impossible so
what are you doing you are copy pasting
your results into the
email or you are creating amazing
PowerPoint presentation or you need to
rewrite everything to web and you know
there are plenty of tools Frameworks for
for uh you know writing a quick web up
in Python only but you still need to
rewrite uh your code to fit in into this
framework and I would like to show you
the the way V writing so you know I I
will show you few tricks that you can
use to convert your notebook into the
web app and share with
others yeah and uh I think two main
features that make mercury different is
that it is user interface framework and
we don't have any callbacks and we don't
have any layout widgets and you
know I I think this is very not
intuitive but I will show you the demo
and I hope you will like it and all
notebooks are uh in our uh GitHub so you
can uh uh check it later I will do live
Cod
okay so and I will start
with uh
with empty
directory
okay so sandbox is my favorite
directory in the whole file system and I
have a lot of different uh projects
there so let's create one
more it will be NYC directory let's go
there okay and I will create the python
virtual
environment so I will show you the
version of the par python I
have okay so I'm using
3.1 okay let's create the virtual
environment
and let's
activate Okay and so the the first step
that I'm doing for all my projects is to
create the requirements uh file with all
needed
packages I will copy the the the ready
requirements from the other uh project
and I will show
you so so we have the the
Mercury mer Mercury package pandas
package mpai package M CP alter VGA data
sets and plotly so so I I will show you
how you can make uh
plots with MP alter and plotly and Vega
data set is for for some example data
set and pandas and newai for data
manipulation okay so let's
install
packages it's good that we have fast
internet
connection uh so the Mercury is uh built
on top of the the jungle so you you
might see uh jungo packages that are
installed
okay okay and I will install
Jupiter okay okay so we have virtual
environment and we have all packages
there so my next step is to create the
kernel for
Jupiter so it will be
python iel
inst and the kernel L will be the same
as
as virtual
environment
okay okay let's start
Jupiter okay so we will create that the
empty notebook Where is
the okay this one okay I will rename the
the note to the
starter
okay so we can start with some
markdown
and write some
header starter
notebook live
Dem okay and we can create some
variables so for example GRE
things
hello and
City
okay and we can just print the readings
and
CD
okay so very simple notebook and you
know it is hard to share even such
simple thing and so you can convert this
notebook
into web app
by adding the the
Mercury package so we can import
Mercury
okay we can convert readings the widget
so just changing the variable to the
widget and we can make it as a select
widget we set the
label
greetings and the value will be
hello and we will have let's say two
choices here the first will be hello and
second will be CH and it is hello in
Polish okay and let's execute this okay
so we have we have a widget the the
widget is displayed in the notebook and
we have two two two values here and we
will change the city perable into the
text widget it is very simple just uh
the text
label will be
CD and the value will be
new
okay
sorry so we have
uh we have widgets in our notebook
already and to use the widget value we
need to change the the
variable we need to add that value
okay
and you can interact with widgets in The
Notebook for example we can change the
readings to chest but but as you see
nothing is happening and to see the
change in the notebook you need to
manually reexecute the sty and it is by
Design and I will show you how this
notebook will look like if you serve it
with Mercury so in I will open the new
terminal I will activate
the the virtual environment and to serve
this notebook as a web app you need to
start the Mercury
server so to do this Type
merury
R
okay and Mercury will find all notebooks
in the current directory and we'll just
serve
or all notebooks from this directory as
a web app okay
and come
on okay so you see we have we have two
two widgets greetings and City and we
have the markdown text and hello New
York okay and here if you change
something so for example you change the
gretings uh the the the the notebook
will be
updated and so as I said we don't have
call boxs in the Frameworks and we don't
have layout widgets
so uh we don't have call box because we
simply reexecute all
cells below updated
widget so for example if we change the
greetings we simply reexecute this cell
and this cell but it is only happening
when when you serve the The Notebook as
a web up so here if we change the New
York to the war
so uh the The Notebook will be
automatically uh re-executed but here if
we change New York to warso
nothing will happen okay you need to
manually run this
code okay and then you you will see the
the the change the we have no layup no
layup widgets so as you see all input
widgets will be always in the sidebar on
the left and it will be always like that
and the Order of widgets in the sidebar
will be the same as the order of widgets
in the notebook so you you see the
greetings is first CD is second the same
here and in the main view you will
see output from from the cells in the
same order as they appear in
the in the in the notebook so we have
the some markdown text at the top and
then you have some
print and here you know you have the
same order
of the output and by by default uh all
code is hidden because as I said most of
the people don't understand P
so
uh okay so it was you know very starter
notebook so what if you would like
uh to change something for example live
demo what what will happen if will
change the for example mark down cell so
for example we we can add something
here okay and if you save the
notebook all changes will uh appear
instantly in the Mercury as well and if
we will add for example
some uh some new widgets for example I
will I will add
uh two two new widgets
okay and very
a okay and I will just
print
okay so we have some some some some new
code and we will see instant update in
the the Mercury as well and we can play
with with widgets and we will
see it is working and you know very
quickly we we we switched from The
Notebook to the web
up okay so I I will show you some nice
features of of mercury so for example
what if you would like to uh show the
code so we have so all the documentation
for mercury are on run mercury.com
website and you have the mentation for
for input and output widgets and custom
widgets so here I I will use the
app uh widget so the app widget can be
used to to specify the title of of
the uh of the app and the
description
okay and it also can used to to show or
hide the
code
true okay let's turn
it okay so you see that the the code is
displayed right now and we have the
starter notebook it is a title of the
application and we have some description
from start notebook and the description
is used in the main view so you can have
several notebooks
here uh okay and what if you have a lot
of parameters and you you would like to
set parameters values and then click the
Run button and and then you would like
to to have the update in the notebook so
we have the the argument continuous
update and uh by default it is true but
we can set it
false and if you set the continuous
update false then you will have
the continuous update
FSE let's say the notbook
okay then you will have the Run button
so you can play with with widgets but
nothing will
happen okay until you press the Run
button and after run
button all cells will be re-executed all
cells below the the up
widget okay so for example what if you
would like to share only static notebook
you can you can set this
static notebook argument
true uh
and there will be no no widgets in the
notebook so you cannot interact with the
notebook and you know it will be
displayed as a static notebook
only and we have a show show
sidebar uh show Side Bar
argument so by default it is true we can
set it to
false so the the sideb part will will be
hidden but you can open
it uh but by default uh the the main
view of the notebook is is using the the
full screen Buton you can switch it off
and use uh display the notebook with
margins you can hide
the the download button and so for
example your users can interact with
with notebook and click download as PDF
and the whole notebook will be
downloaded uh as as a PDF file
so uh you know you can play with
different values and just download as
PDF do you have any
questions
any
yeah the Mery at the command line we
find
URL get people to
run so so here you're running this
locally and then you can run the server
in the cloud
and you put all your notebooks in the in
the cloud and people can interact with
them so I will talk about this later
yeah this is you know just for
development and to check how how it it
looks locally on your
machine okay
and so uh the the common use case in in
notebooks is that you are producing some
files and you would like to produce some
file and make it and your user would
like to download your files that are
produced in the in the notebook so we
have the output directory the special
widget where you can save
your uh where you can save your files
and all files save in the output
directory will be available for download
so I I will show
you uh I will show
you how to save files in the directory
and how how it looks
in
uh in a web so let's let's create
some some uh some files so we'll save to
Output PA and the file name will be exam
txt for
example and we will write
okay and we'll write
the the our
result a Val plus b
value
okay so when we run this uh in the
notebook we will see the
example t t file here in the current
directory and if
we say
notbook and if we open the the the web
up so for example we can set the n
P10 and we have the additional view
output files you can click on it and
have example txt you can download
it and the result is 20 so we can easily
produce files in the notebook and our
users will be able to to download uh the
files and so the next notebook
is I will show you how to to do the
interactive
presentations uh in the Jupiter and how
to share interactive uh
presentations with mer so let's create
the the new
notebook rame
trans
okay okay let's import all
packages
okay so let's make
there
should so to make the presentation we
need
to set the sorry slide slight types for
for each cell so we will skip the the
first cell and we will display the title
slide and so we need to restore the the
the Mery
so it will reload
the the new
notebook
Q okay so we have two notebooks the
starter notebook and the presentation
and right now in the presentation we
have only one
slide okay so let's and in this
presentation we will uh just have the
some scatter plot with some random data
and we'll update the plot in the
presentation during the slideshow so
let's generate some data so uh we'll
have rows
variable will be
slider
playb
we
skip
this okay we have
pause okay
just
ROP call and let's create so we'll skip
this as well and so let's create
some data Frame refal
data
and display the
frame okay so we have data frame with
some random
numbers we'll display the the data
frame and let's do some
chart
okay so will
be okay got plot let's make points
larger okay and let's add
the
maybe some wiget to control the color of
points
okay
that's slide okay let's save
it okay so here we have we have a sideb
with our uh widgets we have slides we
can interact with them change them so in
the when we are displaying the web app
as a presentation we can enter the full
screen mod with f key and you know we
can display this as a full screen
presentation and for example we would
like to to change number of columns in
the data frame then we
just change the the widget and we'll
have more
columns and you know we
can create more columns and can go back
to the go back to the presentation and
in the presentation we have one chart
and we can change
the the data that we are displaying can
change the the color of the points and
you know it is just the example but you
know in the real life you can have as
complex uh data as you want and you can
make nice presentation and your
presentation will be interactive during
the
slideshow okay and I have
uh also few
examples of so this this chart was done
with map. Li and I will show you
examples how to to make how to use alter
or plotly in your in your notebook so I
will copy
some red
no alter example
and
example
okay let's round
Mercury okay so we
have
new
notebook do you know alter
package it's pretty nice so personally I
I prefer out there over the plotly
uh uh so so you know you you have some
notebook out
scaled let's find
it
house we need to change the C
now okay so you
know notebook weave with some alter
plots and in
Mercury you see you have the the we have
new notebook that so in mer we have new
web app we can open open the web up and
interact interact with with
chart and it is nice because alter in
alter you can create the plots for
example with tool
tips okay and the next example is
notebook with plotly and again some some
some chart done with
plotly interactive in the Jupiter
notebook and
let's display it in
Mercury and it is interactive in in
Mercury as
well and you can even so here you have
some animation done with plotly and you
can play
it pretty nice and all all note books
are are in
the uh in our GitHub repository so I
have one more feature that I would like
to show you so for example let's go back
to this uh starter
notebook okay so what if you would like
to uh so you see that the URL of of the
application is
the is the same as the name of the
notebook file I have starter notebook
and the URL is starter as well and what
if you would like to set for example
greetings uh in the URL we have so
let's remove
this
okay so you can you can set the W widget
values from the
URL you need to get add URL
key
greetings and by setting
this you will be able to to to set the
the the widget values and you have the
the share button and you you see you
have
the uh
URL created with the widget value set in
the URL so for example you can share the
URL with some example
values
okay let's go back to the
presentation okay so I show you
some uh some some widgets but uh you
will find the the all all widgets in our
documentation and basically we have
input widgets where you can provide
input to The Notebook we have output
widgets that can be used to display some
uh values uh to the user and we also to
support some uh custom IP
widgets uh but not all are supported so
the few are
listed in our documentation as
well and basically Mercury is working
with any python package so no if it is
working in the notebook then it will
work in Mercury as well so you know you
can use any plotting package in your we
up so it's pretty amazing for
me and so uh
we have some uh features that make uh
web app development easier so for
example you can share as many notebooks
as you want you can easily add
authentication so I I will show you the
demo how to do deployment I will show
you how to add authentication to your
notebooks uh your users can easily
export your their notebooks to the PDF
or HTML you can
create out files in the notebook and
your users will be able to download them
you can embed your notebook in
any website and you can easily hide or
show the
code and as as I show you you can be
build web apps reports dartboards or
pres presentations with with Mercury and
regarding the deployment so as I said
Mercury is created based on J so
basically you can deploy it anywhere
where you have python
installed but deployment can be
sometimes difficult but we we do provide
uh example Docker compost so you can
deploy Mercury on your own uh machines
you can for example share your
local uh deployment with endro or Deploy
on huging face spaces
we also uh provide a commercial license
for self for for selfhosted uh Mercury
uh and in in in a with commercial
license you you get for example uh user
analytics or style
customization and we also have the
Mercury cloud service and I think the
Mercury cloud is the easiest way to
deploy the notebook and I will show you
right now how how to do
this so we have a Ser service that that
is available at cloud. run mercury.com
so after login you will have
the uh the main View and you just add
the site and it will be
by okay and the address will be uh NYC
and you know you can even select several
different domains so for example we can
deploy on run Mercury of course or we
have is data scientist is one is mppp so
you know for me know some pretty nice
domains so our site will be available at
nc. mercury.com and it will be public
let's let's just created okay so the the
the site is ready you know you can check
it so for example we can add some custom
welcome welcome
message create it at live
demo okay let's save
it okay and if we update the the
website
we have up updated welcome message and
we have the the information there are no
notebooks there are no notebooks because
we need to upload some okay let's go to
the upload View and we just need to
select what we would like
to share so let's go here and so if if
you would like to have
some uh packages of course you would
like to then you need to upload the
requirements file with list of your
packages and select your
notebooks
and just upload
them and you know uh so you can see that
uh
alter uh notebook has size 100 kiloby
and pl notebook has size 4
megabytes and you know I think that's
why I I prefer
alter and and I believe plock is loading
whole JavaScript package into the
notebook and that that's why you have
such size and okay so we just uploaded
uh notebooks we need to refresh
the the the website and you know all
your notebooks are are available as web
apps and you know you can just share the
the link and I I told you that it is
easy to to add authentication to your
notebooks
so you just need to change the public to
the
private
okay and
refresh and you know only people that
are log logged in uh will have access to
the to to your
notebooks and uh you can very easily
invite new users so just you know
provide their email address set
permission so permission can view view
notebook or edit notebook so if they
have edit permission they can upload for
example new
notebooks uh
okay so this is the the deployment with
from
Mercury
service and I
think that's all so Mercury code is
available on our GitHub here you have
the go to our
GitHub and happy to answer any
questions a question about um if it's
possible to hand like cases where there
is like put output for example from
API yeah I I think yes yes so case like
Jupiter uh has I don't know to call a
API from Facebook um while it's calling
it needs like some user input and then
this input is used to C against API so
this is okay yeah yeah it is possible
and uh so for example if you are calling
some external API we have uh secrets so
you can add
secrets in to the Mercury and you can
use those secrets in the notebook and
you can call any API and you know you
can use this to connect to some external
databases and so on okay so yeah you can
do
this modification secret something
available to the cloud service uh no it
is available to the op open source
well okay thank
[Applause]
you